We present the Video
Mesh, a new data
structure for video editing.
The Video Mesh encodes
the motion, layering,
and 3D structure of a video
sequence in a unified data
structure.
Intuitively, it looks like a
paper cut out of the world.
We illustrate our technique on
a simple educational example.
Constructing a video
mesh begins with first
tracking distinctive features
through the sequence.
Then we compute a Delaney
triangulation on each frame.
The mesh linearly
interpolates the motion
at vertices, which is a
good approximation where
the motion is smooth.
Users specify
occlusion boundaries
at a few key frames using
splines, which separates
the components in the mesh.
Splines are advected
between key frames
by the optical flow
encoded in the mesh.
Now we change the
viewpoint to reveal
the geometry of the mesh.
The user specifies the
depth at a few vertices.
Now the video mesh looks
like a 2.5D paper cut out.
Notice how the actor's
hand occludes his body
while remaining connected
to it through the arm.
Such self-occlusion cannot
be represented by traditional
layers without arbitrarily
cutting the arm.
In contrast, the
Video Mesh naturally
encodes these topological
configurations.
We use off the shelf matting
to decompose the texture.
We inpaint the missing
parts of the scene
using texture synthesis.
Once we have the
Video Mesh, we can
use classical computer graphics
techniques for special effects.
For instance, we simulate
a large aperture lens
with a shallow depth of
field by rendering the scene
several times from viewpoints
sampled over the aperture.
The user clicks to choose
the plain in focus.
We can also composite a
simulation of volumetric smoke.
Note how the attenuation depends
on the depth of the scene.
This sequence features
a static camera
with complex occlusions
between the columns.
The user needs to specify
only the primary occlusion
boundaries.
Since the camera is
static, we interactively
assign depth using simple
image based modeling tools.
We insert a ground plane and
model the columns and the actor
as vertical facades.
Since the actor is a
single connected component
in the Video Mesh, we can
copy him in space and time
to turn him into a crowd.
Since we have 3D geometry,
we can interactively
manipulate the actor.
We can also refocus the
camera, move the camera,
and simulate the vertigo effect
by moving the camera backward
while zooming in so that
the main object does not
change sides.
Since we have the 3D
geometry of the scene,
we can adjust the
lighting, as well as
simulate a fog
effect that accounts
for the depth at each pixel.
This allows us to
render this sequence
as if it were shot at night.
This sequence features
a moving camera
in a scene with multiple
rigidly moving objects.
We use off the shelf
structure for motion
to recover 3D vertex
positions and the camera path.
In this case,
structure for motion
was applied independently on the
chassis and lid of the copier
and registered into the
same coordinate system.
We composite multiple
copies of another video mesh
into the scene
while interactively
changing the viewpoint.
Notice the parallax induced
by the changing viewpoint.
The inset shows the input video.
This video of a riverbank
near the Notre Dame Cathedral
features complex geometry and
occlusions between buildings.
We model the 3D geometry using
the same image-based tools.
We cut the mesh at the
primary occlusion boundaries
with splines, insert
two ground plains,
and model the buildings
with vertical facades.
The Video Mesh.
Lets us move the camera
onto the roof of the boat
as it sails down the river.